hey David what policies actually make
the most sense to deal with climate
change this is a really good question
particularly in the context of the g20
summit and the United States being the
only of 20 countries that didn't sign on
to the sort of climate change agreement
or intent to work on the issue of
climate change I think the answer the
question properly you really need to
divide it up into short term versus long
term action on climate change we need
some short-term ideas on climate change
to serve as like a bridge or a funnel to
the long term solution that we
ultimately want so number one we need to
understand what causes emissions
emissions are a big part of what we're
trying to ameliorate energy causes huge
emissions transportation causes huge
emissions animal agriculture significant
contributor to emissions manufacturing
of stuff a massive contributor to world
emissions so let's address some of those
with our ideas number one in the short
term carbon taxes ok carbon taxes make
sense in the short term there is some
disagreement among the left as to
whether we want revenue-neutral carbon
taxes or carbon taxes that will raise
revenue which can then be used for
whatever right insert here in either
case study after study has demonstrated
that carbon taxes will incentivize
cleaner manufacturing and cleaner
transportation period number two we
should have targets for X percent
renewables by Y date in the future
sometimes the targets are unrealistic
it'd be great to have realistic but
aggressive targets in either case we
need to be setting goal posts and trying
to reach those goals number three we
should reduce the amount of meat that we
eat there's really no way around that at
this point moving to lab-grown meat is
definitely a possibility that might be
more palatable to people who eat a lot
of meat I am down to eating red meat
probably five times a year and eating
poultry I don't know maybe once every
ten days and beyond that I am tasket
Aryan for most of the time we know that
this is a good thing and until lab-grown
meat becomes a full reality we should be
doing that and then we've got to
incentivize renewable energy like
yesterday I mean right away right now we
are subsidizing a lot of the wrong forms
of energy
fossil fuels oil Trump talks about clean
coal trying to revitalize an industry
that the free market has clearly shown
should be dying coal should be going
away completely we do want to
incentivize the generation of renewable
energy stop incentivizing the continued
harvesting of fossil fuels and and this
is a controversial part I've gone back
and forth on this over the last many
years I'm open to open to using nuclear
as a bridge to get off of fossil fuels
and to renewables but number one takes a
long time to get new renewable on board
I actually don't know that at this point
the timing even makes sense like I'm
conceptually open to nuclear as a bridge
but given how long it takes to actually
start producing new nuclear power I
don't even know that the timeline makes
sense for us geopolitically this is all
really important stuff if we reduce our
demand for fossil fuels this weakens the
leverage that country's hostile to a
half a Venezuela Russia I'm not saying
we should never try to have good
relationships with these countries I'm
merely saying that deleveraging them
when it comes to manipulation and
control over the oil markets would be a
very good thing
geopolitically and a very good thing in
terms of national security yes there may
be short-term pains in terms of gas
taxes or other costs that would be part
of a long term solution but I think that
if we think through it carefully the
government can ensure the
that those who would be most hurt by a
slight uptick in the cost of gas or
other fuel energy sources we can
mitigate those impacts and I think that
we should if I'm missing something here
send me your thoughts I want to hear
from you